[Music]
if an underground organism of
unfathomable size were unearthed in the
united states you might expect
widespread panic at the horrifying
discovery or expect the us government to
block off the cosmic terror from
civilians you might not expect the
entity to be turned into a theme park
marketed towards all ages but that's
what happened with the thankfully
fictional mystery flesh pit national
park the name given to a creature of
indeterminate size and origin that was
nonetheless turned into a tourist
attraction mystery flesh pit is an
ongoing multimedia narrative project by
creator trevor roberts who you can
follow and support in the links below
the story of the pit is told through
flyers advertisements and posters that
rebrand the horrifying life form as a
relaxing family getaway and it's this
upbeat language around something so
blatantly terrifying that makes the
mystery fleshpit project so amusing and
so unsettling just the sort of thing to
cover at this spooky time of year but
since venturing into the darkness of an
unknown organism is a little frightening
to do on one's own edge will be joining
me for this entry he makes great content
about prehistoric life unique modern
animals and bizarre cryptids so he's
just the person to help investigate this
mysterious organism now let's begin our
dissent
unearthed accidentally in the early
1970s the mystery flesh pit also known
as the permian basin super organism is
located in west texas
discovered by oil workers the first
tours of the pit were given by james
jackson a small-time oil man and showman
the mystery flesh pit was then further
studied and reinforced by anadyne inc a
deep mining corporation who opened the
park as a tourist attraction in 1976
with assurances it was perfectly safe we
know how corporations are
in selling the park to the public
anodyne downplayed the horrifying nature
of the pit itself creating a friendly
cartoon mascot caver coop who assured
families the pit was nothing to be
afraid of the attraction was later
absorbed into the national park system
in the early 1980s which led to the
permian basin super organism becoming
further normalized
surprising absolutely no one thousands
of tourists regularly exploring the
inside of an unknown organism would
eventually prove to be a bad idea as the
infamous 2007 disaster would prove but
that's a story we'll get to later
for now let's try to piece together the
material the author has given us to try
and understand the pit's biology like so
many aspects of the pit the more
visceral reality of the organism was
glossed over with clinical language by
the professionals who first studied it
since an organism of this size defied
conventional science numerous new
disciplines were founded to help
understand it geobiology is the term
used for how the organism interacts with
its environment looking at this early
map you can see the lifeform possesses
muscular skeletal nervous limbic and
vascular systems similar to traditional
life at least on the top layers this
cross-section of the pit however might
just be a small fragment of a larger
more complex organism how large
data collected from a series of
boreholes shown in this diagram suggests
that in some places the organism extends
over 30 kilometers below the earth's
surface for reference the marianas
trench is only 11 kilometers deep indeed
the author suggests that the pit may
well extend into the earth's mantle with
some of the imaginary scientists
implying that the organism may be native
to the interior of the planet having
merely surfaced to the upper tectonic
plates for unknown reasons and despite
public assurances to the contrary
there's evidence that people working
behind the scenes long understood the
super organism to be dangerous at one
point in this fictional alternate
history the u.s government launched an
investigation into the feasibility of
using nuclear weapons to kill the life
form although only the cover of this
report was ever photographed the
conclusion seemed to be a resounding no
what made the permian basin
superorganism so potentially
catastrophic the answers may lie deeper
within
in the early days of the pit a mission
called project freefall was planned to
chart the organism to a greater depth
than ever before
a joint effort between the u.s
government and russian scientists the
expedition involved a six-person team
lowered into the pit via specialized
vehicle over a period of two weeks the
pod descended down the dark wet squishy
pit reaching regions that had never been
explored before at last the probe
drilled through a dense layer of lower
cartilage and entered an unknown region
of blue tissue a single person pod was
lowered into this opening the russian
pilot described a reflective and
prismatic environment of which we only
have a single image from this on-board
computer when the pod was raised back to
the surface it was heavily damaged and
the pilot was missing
the researchers concluded an attack from
an unknown organism was the likely cause
project free fall makes it clear that
the organic section of the mystery
fleshpit is merely a portion of the life
form and other regions are unlike
anything in the natural world it also
made it clear people aren't alone in the
pit
even above the deeper layers which
weren't available to the public hostile
wildlife was frequently encountered
large crustacean-like organisms were
spotted as early as the first
explorations which this early sketch
shows
in typical mystery flesh-bit fashion
however the corporate higher-ups turned
these terrifying life forms into part of
the marketing wildlife safety brochures
were handed out to visitors explaining
the exciting anatomical fauna that
dwelled in the pit and how to avoid
getting eaten at the foundation of the
pit's ecosystem playing a role similar
to bacteria in the bodies of regular
sized animals were macrobacteria unlike
regular bacteria you can only spot under
a microscope macrobacteria were
multicellular goliaths that could reach
lengths of 12 feet or 4 meters across
this educational chart produced by the
park services showcases the various
types of macrobacteria and the other
bizarre species that dwell in this
imaginary permian basin superorganism we
won't be able to cover them all but one
notable species is the mesogalil
tridecapod an insect-like organism that
gets its name from its 13 legs as this
faded wild about nature infographic will
tell you these pseudo-vertebrates are
almost the size of humans and aren't
technically vampires as this guide will
assure you although they do feed off the
pit and look like something out of my
nightmares in other areas of the pit
there were sightings of other more
dangerous species and even rumors of
human-like life-forms called marrow folk
which inodine inc strongly denied they
maintained the mystery flesh pit was
just like any other national park and
anyone who mysteriously vanished just
didn't read their brochure carefully
enough
with the permian basin super organism so
hostile to human life excavating it was
a challenge
a challenge that began with finding
people to staff it
as this oddly hilarious park ranger
recruitment bulletin suggests however
with the right benefits and incentives
anodyne inc was in fact able to find
people willing to enlist in the mystery
fleshpit park ranger program
what kinds of jobs did this entail well
why not become a park trail engineer
this anxiety-inducing position involved
using compact stent frames and other
highly specialized tools to create new
pathways within the pit to be a park
trail engineer required extensive
knowledge of caving geology and
macrobiology as attacks from local
wildlife were apparently common
for personal protection the laser scope
anatomical environmental multi-tool was
the most reliable defense
intended to blast new paths within the
mystery fleshpit this portable tool an
example of which is on display here was
frequently used to ward off aggressive
life forms to more safely traverse the
pit's interior anodyne inc developed the
internal anatomy vehicle or iav a
vehicle that could traverse the slickest
and steepest of routes
its maneuverability came in part from a
rotating mechanical joint that connected
the front of the vehicle to the
midsection
as tourism increased the larger
ventarial environment excursion vehicle
was developed which we know from
schematics used a set of twin
counter-oriented screws for propulsion
these safari vessels could seat up to
eight park guests and take them deep
into the pits with supposed safety
supposed being the key word here as a
mock-up of an incident report tells us
that vehicles were bent melted crushed
dented or dissolved at least on some
occasions maybe traversing the unknown
depths of a giant organism isn't a good
idea after all
well as kaver dave might say that's not
the right attitude for exploring the
funder ground for adventurous park
guests the opportunity of camping on
natural unreinforced trails was possible
with the interventarial tent shown here
in this diagram unlike traditional tents
this collapsible multi-sided device
could endure the crushing shifts and
deadly wildlife of the pit while campers
slept at least most of the time when
things went wrong emergency trail phones
were one way to reach the park staff
called lighthouses by seasoned hikers
these subterranean telecommunication
devices were highly advanced for the
1970s and indeed the study of the
permian basin superorganism led to
numerous technological breakthroughs
one of many lucrative results from the
development of the fictional pit were
tremendous advances in the field of
computer science in the early 1980s
anodyne began to release computers made
of nervous tissue taken from the permian
basin superorganism with four terabytes
of organic tissue storage memory these
machines were extremely popular
an even more well-known product exported
from the mystery flesh pit was amniotic
ballast a miraculous fluid from deep
within the pit branded as vita salve in
advertisements such as this one
the product could cure various illnesses
and was almost certainly safe to use
but the most notable service anodyne
offered was access to the mystery flesh
pit itself aside from hiking tourists
paid for access to the amniotic thermal
springs the springs had strong effects
on visitors who bathed in them including
making their skin healthier and giving
them a euphoric sensation as long as
they could take their mind off the fact
they were bathing in an unknown liquid
the true focus of the pit for most
visitors however was the lower visitor
center a gateway into the deep that took
eight years to construct with restrooms
a gift shop and even restaurants the
lower visitor center was the hub of the
national park
was it a good idea to suspend a several
ton building on steel cables in the
middle of the pit anodyne inc soon found
out
at last we've come to the 2007 disaster
and all that follows on july 4th 2007
due to anodyne's negligence
something as simple as heavy rain and a
faulty water pump caused a section of
the pit to flood to unsafe levels the
result was a catastrophe most had never
imagined the permian basin superorganism
began to wake up
imagine waking up from a long nap to
find hundreds of tiny bugs had built a
miniature hotel in your throat you'd be
pretty mad at 9 52 pm the lifeform began
a choking response due to the flooding
causing the entire lower visitor center
to be crushed and swallowed deeper into
its skullet but this was just the
beginning according to an incident
report the creature then started to
surface with people living all around
west texas witnessing limbs of the
superorganism rising from the ground the
scale of which is captured in this
impressionistic painting from a survivor
and then the creature returned to its
slumber likely lulled back to sleep by a
mysterious contingency measure redacted
from the incident report in the wake of
the disaster anodyne inc was dissolved
and the park was finally closed to the
public with people perhaps finally
realizing that hiking inside a giant
creature isn't such a good idea after
all
the author imagines that the region
around the pit has now become a ghost
town but behind fences some are still
monitoring it in the present of this
alternate timeline the permian basin
superorganism is now kept under constant
surveillance but who knows when it might
awaken once more
there's a lot more lurking in the pit
you can read about online and you can
follow and support trevor roberts by
using the links in the description below
or by purchasing something from the
mystery flesh pit gift shop and special
thanks to edge for helping me archive
this mysterious organism
i've been destined from the channel edge
i cover all sorts of topics and natural
history whether it's the extinct beasts
of times long since past the bizarre and
sticky world of the living or the
extraordinary dark places our minds go
to in the supernatural or
cryptozoological if you like curious
archive ben g thomas or tray the
explainer you'll enjoy me and my content
as well follow the links to my channel
in the description and comment section
below and as always thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this entry please lend
your support and like subscribe and hit
the notification icon to stay up to date
on all things curious see you in the
next video
you